vamos a tratar de ver si podemos obtener
una idea mucho más intuitiva del teorema
del valor medio aunque entonces vamos a
estudiar el teorema teorema del valor
medio ok y verás que una vez que
dominemos ya la digamos la notación
matemática en verdad es muy intuitivo
entonces pensemos en el teorema del
valor medio y para eso vamos a les vamos
a hablar de una función f digamos que
tenemos una función f y vamos a empezar
a pedirle condiciones a esta efe en
principio tiene que ser continua ya
saben que continua significa que no
tenga hoyos que no tenga saltos bruscos
en fin y que f sea continua en algún
intervalo cerrado
digamos que empieza en algún número a y
que termine en algún número b muy bien
entonces vamos a tener este intervalo
cerrado y ahí va a ser continua ahora
otra cosa que hay que pedirle a
a efe es que sea derivable derivable
sea derivable en el intervalo abierto
a lo mejor tú te estás te estarás
preguntando qué significan intervalos
abiertos y cerrados bueno por si no lo
has visto los intervalos cerrados nos
está diciendo que hay b están incluidos
en este conjunto de números mientras que
los intervalos abiertos dice que hay b
no están incluidos pero si todos los que
están entre ellos muy bien entonces como
veríamos una función de este estilo
déjenme ver si puedo dibujar aquí los
ejes ahí tenemos un eje
lg y por acá voy a pintar
hay más o menos tienen el eje x y voy a
pintar aquí bueno aquí va a estar el
punto a digamos que por acá está el
punto ve muy bien y voy a pintar una
función que vaya de algún punto por aquí
hasta por acá muy bien entonces aquí lo
que tenemos este punto tiene una altura
de fedea esto corresponde a lo que a la
función evaluada en a mientras que de
este lado este punto de aquí
y más o menos así este de aquí
corresponde a efe debe muy bien esta es
la función evaluada en b y cómo ven la
la curva es suave porque pedimos que sea
derivable en el intervalo abierto ok
entonces con estas condiciones lo que me
va a decir el teorema del valor medio va
a decir que existe algún punto cuya
pendiente de la recta tangente en ese
punto coincide con la con la pendiente
de la recta o más bien con la p
digamos con la tasa promedio de cambio
muy bien qué quiere decir eso con
dibujitos si pensamos en la tasa
promedio de cambios simplemente no
pensamos en estos dos puntos y los
unimos con una línea los unimos
una ops
esa línea no quedó muy derecha
los unimos con una línea va de nuevo
ahí lo tienen ya unimos esos puntos con
una línea esta línea esta línea secante
que une este punto con este otro en
realidad
su pendiente es la la tasa de cambio
promedio de esta función en este
intervalo ahora el teorema del valor
medio me dice que va a haber algún punto
por aquí en medio cuya donde la
pendiente de la recta tangente en ese
punto coincide con la pendiente de la
recta secante que uno de los puntos
inicial y final o lo que es lo mismo la
pendiente instantánea en este punto
corresponde a la pendiente promedio de
esta función también por ejemplo
podríamos tener una aquí quizás no se ve
tan claro más o menos pero aquí
podríamos tener otro muy bien entonces
el teorema del valor medio nos dice que
existirá un punto donde el cambio y aquí
estamos vamos a pensar el cambio en y de
toda la función en este intervalo
dividido entre el cambio en x y entonces
eso corresponde
y digamos aquí está nuestro cambio
aquí está el taller acá estará nuestro
cambio en x aquí está nuestro camión x
entonces esto es la pendiente de esta
recta secante será igual a quien será
igual a efe efe db - efe de verdad que
es justo esta altura tenemos fpv y le
quitamos esta que se fedea y luego
dividimos todo entre b menos a b menos a
es justamente la longitud de esta base
entonces esto que es la pendiente de la
recta secante coincidirá con alguna
derivada de algún punto eso está esto ya
lo estamos diciendo en términos
matemáticos entonces si la función
cumple estas dos propiedades podemos
garantizar que existe un punto
digamos que se encuentra en el intervalo
abierto a b es decir que no es ni a que
no es y tampoco es b
de hecho vamos a ponerlo con sus colores
correspondientes
y ve entonces existe un punto ce en en
el intervalo abierto a b donde donde se
cumple que está pendiente será igual a
la derivada en ese punto ce ok entonces
todo lo que me está diciendo el teorema
del valor medio es que la tasa de cambio
instantánea en algún punto se que por
ejemplo podría ser este que pintamos
aquí o podría ser este que que más o
menos se puede ver en el dibujo la tasa
de cambio instantánea en esos puntos
bueno bueno al menos dice que hay al
menos un punto en donde esa esa tasa de
cambio instantánea será igual a la tasa
de cambio promedio de la función en el
intervalo cerrado en los siguientes
vídeos vamos a tratar de hacer un poco
más de ejercicios para que quede más
clara la idea del teorema del valor
medio